[Music]
french people have an important decision
to make
they are due to vote for leader in april
there are two rounds first to narrow
down the field and then to pick a winner
whoever they choose to live here in the
presidential palace for the coming five
years will shape crucial french policies
where they keep the centrists emmanuel
macron in charge or choose a new
president
usually french elections are domestic
knock-about affairs
recently they've been lost and won on
topics like globalization and economics
[Applause]
this time though it's all happening in
the shadow of the ukraine war
the russian army has rolled into
european cities
millions of people are leaving looking
for safety
and the global economy still in uproar
from the pandemic is being hit with
soaring prices
in the midst of all that french politics
must continue and the people must elect
a president
as ever it all comes down to fundamental
french values liberty equality
fraternity and
democracy values from the french
revolution the basis of the republic
even nowadays citizens keep them in mind
when they vote
i'm lisa louis in paris i've been
reporting from here for more than 10
years you're going to hear from four
voters with very different backgrounds
they told me how these fundamental
values are motivating them in this
election
[Music]
i'm marina strauss in brussels
i'm going to tell you how the rest of
europe and the world see what's
happening in france
and why they care who's going to lead
the country
emmanuel macron the incumbent president
emmanuel macron stepped to power in the
last presidential election five years
ago he stole on a central platform and
won support from all political camps his
victory seemed to bury france's
traditional system of center left and
center right and many people voted for
him as the least worst option to keep
the far right out this time around lots
of people observers commentators and
polls predict macron will win again and
yet we found many people who were fed up
with him even in this time of crisis
that might be true for france
but on the world stage macro has gained
quite some reputation in just five years
he has managed to put france and himself
in the spotlight right from the start
macro presented himself as a big
europhile as someone who's willing to
fight for greater european integration
and more recently he was the world
leader who tried to convince russian
president vladimir putin to end his war
in ukraine
[Music]
and yet a bunch of people have joined
him as candidates they all want to do
well enough in the first round of fating
to face him in the runoff these
challenges include
marine le pen the established far-right
candidate she's running for president
for the third time she took over what
was the national front in 2011
and then renamed it to national rally
trying to escape the legacy of her
father jean-marie convicted multiple
times for downplaying the holocaust and
inciting racial hatred
marine le pen is very well known around
here she was a member of the european
parliament for many years
while promising to take france out of
the eu
so nowadays she no longer promotes a
brexit
but her eurosceptic fuse would make her
a very difficult partner for many here
in brussels
eric zemor is also on the far right and
can sound even more radical than le pen
valerie picres is from the center-right
republican party but is moving further
right
jean-luc milan from the far left is the
only left winger with any chance of
getting to the second round
the choice voters make between these
different candidates will come down to
fundamental french values
[Music]
is
[Music]
communists the french sometimes accept
limits on their liberty without great
uproar france has some of the world's
toughest anti-terrorism laws but the
security law provoked outrage the stated
idea was to protect police officers from
malicious public identification and the
constitutional court struck it down
saying it was too vague but the attempt
and the repression of protests against
it left a sour taste of a government
trying to suppress liberty of expression
[Music]
opinions
[Music]
she was one of those willing to take a
deep breath and vote for my car five
years ago that was in the second round
when the choice was him or marine le
[Music]
she's not alone macron picked up voters
from all sides of the political spectrum
in that runoff vote he took 71 percent
of far-left voters
65 percent of socialist voters
and 57 percent of conservative voters
but are they still worried enough about
le pen to vote for him again
absolutely
so
she's right many decisions are taken at
the european level
but it's the 27 eu leaders whose dear
things right-wing populist leaders in
europe would certainly welcome a le pen
victory
she already has close ties with poland's
and hungary's leaders
[Music]
but a president le pen
would strain the relationship with
germany
and that's not something many europeans
want at all let alone at the time of
crisis
[Music]
um
the yellow west movement was a huge deal
starting in november 2018
hundreds of thousands of people occupied
france's streets and roundabouts in
deep-rooted anger and despair
[Music]
were mostly people from the lower middle
class who felt they could no longer make
ends meet
[Music]
foreign
price increases for everyday necessities
have added to worries for people like
luzak
everything has become more expensive
over the last year
fresh food
fuel
and energy
avon memory lager on ukraine
presidential candidates have promised to
help those that are struggling with
things like better pay lower taxes or a
one-off bonus they see polls showing
that spending power is top french
priority in this election but many like
lozak don't believe these promises
um
that shrinking trust is a problem across
europe but the eu needs france to be
unified and strong
it's the bloc's second biggest economy
one of its founding members
a crucial partner for its neighbor
germany if french citizens don't trust
their own leader this will also reduce
faith in eu decisions
yet
french disappointment with macron seems
to run deep
for marilyn
[Laughter]
[Music]
is
[Music]
was one of the initiators of france's
first anti-racism demonstration back in
1983.
it was a very different country back
then
period
the march was triggered by several
murders of young second generation
migrants
despite this
immigrants believed the french system of
democracy with its fundamental values
would eventually integrate them
[Music]
reports plus
uh
according to recent poll 63 of the
people living here say there are too
many migrants in france that attitude
does not help brussels with the job of
trying to find a coordinated approach
to migration and asylum in the eu
macron and other eu leaders responded to
the arrival of many migrants and
refugees in 2015 by strengthening the
eu's external borders
to keep out as many people as possible
if one of macron's contenders to the
right won the election
there would be even less chance of a
european policy to distribute and settle
migrants and refugees in
europe and yet when it comes to the war
in ukraine french attitudes look very
different a full eighty percent feel
favorable towards refugees from there
and within a few weeks the french
government set up shelters to host 100
000 ukrainians
[Music]
respect
a
the
obviously beats on the left and yet he
is one of those still willing to vote
for emmanuel macron in order to keep
marine le pen away from the presidency
[Music]
b
many people of her age simply do not
vote in the last presidential and
parliamentary elections in 2017
19.4 percent of 18 to 24 year olds
didn't take part
among 25 to 29 year olds the figure was
23.9
but it's not just her age that makes
lulu less likely to vote she lives in
the suburbs where abstention rates
amongst the young hit record highs she
grew up in cliche subway north of paris
in france's poorest department that's
known for having been a hot spot for
youth rights in the past full of law it
felt a very long way away from
politicians in the capitol
when she was 16 she ended up in a school
in a rich part of paris for several
months
she saw how well-informed her wealthy
classmates were about politics
and she felt that people like herself
should also have a say that's why in
2018 she founded a group to spread that
message amongst other young people from
the suburbs
plan to also visit young people in the
countryside and even to go abroad
because high abstention rates amongst
young voters is not a purely french
phenomenon is it marina you're right
lisa it's not
all over the world young people are less
likely to vote than older citizens but
europeans may find it especially
disappointing when french young people
don't vote we still see france as the
cradle of european democracy
the home of the big democratic values
we've been talking about
europe will expect france's leader to
show the world that these values are
taken seriously
[Music]
so whoever wins in april will have much
to do to revive french fundamental
values it'll be needed though to help
people regain trust in their politicians
and their institutions and to make sure
that france remains a reliable european
partner we at dw will be reporting on
the election results and the impact here
in france and on what these results will
mean for the world and for europe in
particular
the french fundamental values liberty
equality fraternity and democracy
are also fundamental european values
the war in ukraine and the instabilities
it's creating
mean that europe needs a stable and
strong france
more than ever
okay we're done
[Music]
great coffee thank you
[Music]
you